[Music]
now a hearing on the original film of
the assassination of president kennedy
yesterday the assassination records
review board considered whether the
government should buy the film shot by
amateur photographer abraham zapruder or
return it to private hands
the board heard from a film expert a law
professor and the authors of several
books on jfk's assassination
this meeting took place at the national
archives in washington and lasts two and
a half hours
[Music]
just
a call to order this
public meeting public hearing of the
associ assassination records review
board
thank you all for coming today i want to
first
express my appreciation the appreciation
of the board
to the national archives for permitting
us to meet in this historic reception
room
and we're happy to be here and happy to
be able to use the facilities this is
not a a meeting or a function of the
national archives
the assassination records review board
is an independent federal agency not
part of the national archives
i would ask that everyone
take care with the antiques
and old furniture and rugs that are in
this building uh in this room we'd
appreciate that
i also want to thank our witnesses today
for agreeing to participate in this
important hearing for the board
a little information about the board the
assassination records review board the
members were appointed by president
clinton confirmed by the senate in 1994
we have been at work now for
almost three years working on
implementing the
president john f kennedy assassination
records collection act of 1992.
we primarily have been locating securing
and releasing to the public
records related to the tragic
assassination of president kennedy
much of the records that have been
released are records that have been held
in federal government files we also have
been on the search for additional
records whether they be in the hands of
state and local governments
or in the hands of private individuals
who
may wish to
donate their material to the united
states
this has resulted in a grow ever growing
collection of records
of the assassination
at the national archives at college park
upwards of nearly three and a half
million pages are now available to the
public
at the national archives
the goal of the assassination records
review board is is the goal of was the
goal of congress in passing the records
collection act
is to ensure the broadest possible
public release
of the records
of the assassination of president
kennedy
relevant records which were created
before the assassination
and certainly all of the records of its
investigatory aftermath
it is not i emphasize it's not the
responsibility of the review board to
solve remaining mysteries associated
with the assassination
or to reach conclusions about the
assassination itself
rather it is the duty of the board and
the responsibility of the board to
secure
and release to the public to the
greatest extent possible
the records that unfortunately have
remained shrouded
in secrecy through so many years since
the event in nineteen sixty three
let me turn to uh today's hearing the
purpose of today's hearing
is to seek
public comment and advice on what should
be done
with the camera original motion picture
film
of the assassination
that was taken by
abraham zapruder
on november 22 1963.
that film has been stored
the original has been stored at the
national archives
it was placed there by mr zapruder's
heirs
which now have have formed a company
and they claim to possess legal title to
the film
so the review board is faced with the
question of how to properly handle this
artifact the original camera original
film from the day of the assassination
we have assembled today for
a testimony an interesting group of
experts related to legal issues that are
associated with this question
and certainly issues relative to the
value of the camera original film
taken by abraham zapruder the film
itself
i'd like to ask before we begin uh
whether any of the other review board
members have any comments that they'd
like to make before we get into the
witnesses
anyone wish to
okay
again i appreciate all of you coming
today thank you for attending this
hearing
we're going to hear first from the
general counsel for the assassination
records review board mr jeremy gunn who
is going to outline some of the issues
that are presented to the review board
by the zapruder film mr gunn
thank you mr chairman members of the
review board dr marwell
the meetings of this board are regulated
by the federal law called the government
in the sunshine act
under the sunshine act the review
board's deliberation should be open to
the public except to the extent that the
deliberations would involve issues
relating to national security or
certain types of legal strategy
the vast majority of the board's
deliberations to date have been in
closed meetings where issues of national
security have been discussed in the
records that the board has reviewed
question now before the board is what
action it should take if any with regard
to the disposition of the original
zapruder film it necessarily involves
discussion of issues that are properly
within the public domain but it also
involves issues that may involve some
type of legal strategy
in my opinion the board is acting
properly in holding this open meeting
and to the greatest extent possible
deliberating publicly about issues that
are of public
concern
like to provide a little bit of
background about the zapruder film the
conventional story of the zapruder film
is as follows mr abraham zapruder was a
clothing manufacturer in dallas texas
who had his company uh was located near
dealey plaza on november 22nd mr
zapruder took his late model bell and
howell zoom camera containing double
eight millimeter kodak film two dele
plaza to record the presidential
motorcade
the film that he took there is now use
universally regarded as including some
of the most important images of the
actual assassination
after the motorcade passed the secret
service learned of his film and
accompanied him to a kodak laboratory in
dallas
where the original film was developed
they then went to jameson film company
which made three copies which i'll refer
to as the first day copies of the
original film
two of those first day copies were
loaned to the secret servant service and
are now in the hands and in the custody
of the national archives they are the
property of the u.s government
the third first day film along with the
original was subsequently sold as i will
get into in a moment
now when i refer to the
terms original and camera original i'm
describing what is generally thought to
have been the film that was actually in
mr zapruder's camera at the time the
motorcade passed i will use the term
copy to refer to any image that was made
from that original film
some researchers believe that what we
are calling here today the camera
original may not in fact be the camera
original film i'm going to continue to
use the term camera original to describe
what is commonly understood without any
prejudice to whether in fact that is the
original film or not or whether there
may indeed be a copy that or a film that
precedes that
shortly after the
uh
the film was developed mr zapruder sold
the original film and his uh remaining
first day copy to time inc
although there has been some controversy
in the past regarding the amount that mr
zapruder was actually paid by time mag
or time inc the record reflects that he
received a 25 000 cash payment which he
then gave to the dallas to police
department for the widow of officer
tippett
and he received subsequent payments of
totaling approximately 150 000 dollars
over a several year time span
life magazine which then had the
original film published some frames of
the zapruder film as early as november
29 1963
and in some subsequent issues during the
following two years
in 1975 time life sold the original
film to lmh company for one dollar
the shareholders of lmh company are the
widow and the children of mr zapruder
who now is deceased
in 1978 lmh company placed the original
film in the national archives under a
storage agreement lmh company believes
today that it currently possesses legal
title to this film that is now located
in the national archives
although the public does not now have
access to the original film this would
not necessarily change if the u.s
government were to have cus or have
possession rights over the original film
the archives keeps the film in cold
storage what i understand to be 25
degrees fahrenheit in archi archivally
sound conditions
the original film due to shrinkage
cannot now be shown on a standard motion
picture projector
the possible uses of the original today
would that thus be presumably limited to
forensics examinations of the film as to
well as well as to making master copies
of the film either inter-negatives or in
her positives of the film
at the archives today there are still
slide copies of the film that are
available for examination
copies of individual frames as well as
the film itself are widely available to
the public in books magazines videos
motion pictures and there is even a
version on cd-rom
one of the questions that the board
needs to consider under the jfk act is
whether the
zapruder film is an assassination record
within the meaning of the act the review
board's authority of course derives from
the jfk act which was passed by congress
in 1992.
the jfk act itself provides for
the quote expeditious public transfer of
assassination records to the national
archives so the question is raised is
this zapruder film an assassination
record that should be in the jfk
collection at the archives and
essentially should that be federal
government property rather than the
property of private citizens
to some extent
the statute answers
at least part of this question under the
jfk act an assassination record includes
among other records
any quote or quote any record that is
related to the assassination of
president john f kennedy that was made
available for use by the warren
commission
the record reflects that the zapruder
film the original zapruder film was
explicitly and specifically requested by
the warren commission and the warren
commission and the staff were shown
versions of the origin or shown the
original zapruder film
this would seem to suggest that within
the statutory definition the zapruder
film qualifies as being an assassination
record moreover the board independently
from prior statements believes that the
original film is an assassination record
within the meaning of its own
regulations
now at this public hearing today there
are things that i understand the board
will be doing and things that they're
not be doing in order that there be some
clarity i'll try and suggest some of the
things that i think the board is not
going to be
doing
[Music]
the board is not seeking comment from
the public regarding whether the
zapruder film is is one of the most
important records of the assassination
the reason the board would not be
considering this is that that is a
foregone conclusion that that is the
case
the board already acknowledges this uh
nor is the record nor is there a
question whether the zapruder film is an
assassination record under the jfk act
as i have just outlined nor does the
board question whether in the ideal
world were no costs involved whether the
zapruder film ought to be possessed by
the us government and placed in the
archives
the board also is not undertaking today
any examination regarding the
authenticity of the zapruder film
although it is aware of the controversy
surrounding those allegations
the board also is not holding a hearing
on whether lmh company possesses legal
title to the zapruder film that would to
the extent that that is a controversy be
a matter for the courts similarly the
board is not a is evaluating the
validity of lmh companies copyright
interest in the film that also would be
a matter for the courts
rather the core question for the board
today is whether it should undertake an
action that would affect a taking in
constitutional terms of the original
film or whether the board should seek a
negotiated arrangement with the zapruder
family now lmh company that would
attempt to a
make high quality copies of the zapruder
film easily available to the public for
the first time
b
provide for forensic testing of the film
to determine in part any questions
related to authenticity
and c would ensure that the u.s congress
has an option if it so chooses to
purchase the film
so the choice then for the review board
is to some extent should the film be
taken and transferred to the jfk
collection the archives or should a
negotiated arrangement be made that
would include some terms that would make
copies of the film easily available to
the public i'd like to outline the
parameters of the two options before the
board so the first one is the the taking
option
the first witness who will
be following me professor brown ice will
discuss some of the constitutional and
statutory issues involving how the
federal government takes private
property for public use i am in somewhat
of a con quandary in that i am the
general counsel for the board and the
board is entitled to my confidential
legal advice which i have attempted to
provide
and i
believe it would be inappropriate for me
to explain express
my own opinions on this matter in this
particular forum but professor brown ice
will examine those issue from his
perspective
should the review board believe that a
taking is appropriate it would instruct
presumably the archivist of the united
states that the zapruder film should be
transferred to the jfk collection of the
archives now to one extent that is a
paper transfer the film would be
continued to be stored in exactly the
same location but rather than having the
lmh company be recorded as the owner the
us government would be the owner of the
film
although there are several possible
develops that might follow from that
instruction by the board one likely
scenario is that lmh company would then
sue the federal government in the united
states court of federal claims
and demand just compensation for having
been deprived of its property the
department of justice would then
presumably represent the united states
and the review board in any
following litigation
if the court were to agree that the
review board has the authority to
transfer the film the court would then
presumably determine the value of the
film and order that lmh company be
compensated out of funds from the u.s
treasury
under this particular scenario congress
would not need to make any
particularized appropriation of funds
for the film
although payments nevertheless are
derived from funds appropriated by
congress for this litigation fund
if the board were to
attempt in a negotiated arrangement
option it would likely follow along the
following uh
what likely contain the following
provisions
first
lmh would agree to make the best
available copy of the zapruder film
using the best available technology best
available current technology the high
quality copy would include images that
are between the sprocket holes on the
original film
a digitized version of this film or of
the original film could then be made
second lmh would agree to make this high
quality copy available to researchers
for their individual use thus to the
extent that lmh has a perfected
copyright interest in the film they
would agree to license
to some extent the use of
the high quality images
although the third although it would be
copies would be available at cost to the
public from the archives lmh would
nevertheless continue to possess
whatever copyright interest it would
have in the film thus although members
of the public could then easily purchase
for the first time high quality images
of the film for their individual use the
license agreement with the archives
would not provide that members of the
public would be entitled to make
subsequent commercial use of that film
so a member of the public could request
the film obtain a copy of it they could
not then under this arrangement go out
and redistribute that or put it into a
movie or put it into a book and make
profits
on it
fourth
congress would be given an option to
purchase the film exception such an
option could be formulated in different
ways nevertheless an agreement would
provide that congress would be given an
opportunity to purchase the film to
place that in the archives or to keep
have the government have permanent
possession of it in the archives
finally the basic term that would likely
be involved in such a negotiated
agreement the government would be
willing would be able to conduct all
appropriate forensic tests of the
original film including any and all
tests that would reasonably answer the
question of the film's authenticity
i think that there are a few questions
the board
ought to consider from
the
experts who have been called here today
and from other members of the public who
will be speaking and i'd like to give
some suggestions of the sorts of
questions that would be appropriate
first
in regard to the camera original film
does the original zapruder film possess
an intrinsic historical value such the
review board should take action to
ensure that the original is kept at the
national archives
regardless of
costs
second what harms might befall the
original if the government does not
acquire the film for example could a
private purchaser purchase the film from
lh company cut the film into
individual frames and then sell that on
the public thus destroying the integrity
of the original film
another question is is the original film
itself a wasting asset in the sense that
it has deteriorated over time and that
it will continue to deteriorate over
time so that conceivably a copy of the
film right now may be worth more for its
evidentiary value than would the
original film be 20 years from now
that's a question for the experts
over time will a copy well
next question could a high quality copy
of the film which includes images
between the sprockets satisfy all of the
legitimate needs of researchers and
scholars
and if not which specific needs would
not be satisfied by a copy of the
original
another question is could such need to
be addressed by the governments
conducting a foreign forensics
examination could a panel of experts be
assembled who could look at the original
film and make determinations regarding
either the speed of which the film went
the significance of the images between
the the holes
and other technical questions that have
come up regarding the the zapruder film
finally in this area there's a question
whether possible future technology not
known today using the original film may
be able to answer questions that cannot
be answered through current technology
questions that would seem to be also
appropriate if
for the question of whether there is the
statutory authority to take the film are
as follows
what actions may the review board
legally and properly take in order to
ensure that the public has access to the
original and to high quality copies of
the film
if the board believes that the film
should be owned by the u.s government
should the taking be by an action of the
review board or is that an action that
should be taken by congress
another question is whether the review
board under the jfk act has the legal
authority to take the zapruder film
another question is what are the
possible consequences of the boards
attempting to take the original film
what are the possible consequences of
the boards not attempting to take the
original film
another question which uh may be of
interest to the board is what monetary
value should be attached to the film
now i should say to the public here that
the board has received incompetence
monetary appraisals of the zapruder film
that were conducted by experts retained
by the department of justice and by lmh
company in cooperation with each other
so the board has had some information
which is
currently protected on some valuations
and which the board is
free to either accept or reject in its
best judgment
to say that
the
zapruder film is invaluable or is
important does not really answer the
question of what monetary
value should be attached to the film
if the film were taken by the jfk act or
if congress were to purchase the film
the legal owner would still need to be
compensated
how much should the government pay to
compensate the original owner
finally is there a cost beyond which the
government should not take the original
should it be up to a certain amount it
would be appropriate for either the
review board of the congress to take the
film but beyond that amount it would not
be appropriate those are all questions
confronting the board and finally a
question that the board should consider
is whether the board if it decides not
to
take action to
take the zapruder film should it urge
congress to take the film thank you very
much
any uh questions or comments from mr
gunn while we have him up here
it's my favorite kind of question
thank you
as usual you've raised a lot of
questions uh for us to to ponder today
next we'd like to hear from
robert brownis who is associate
professor at the george washington
university law school
and an expert on the takings issue
welcome professor brown eyes thank you
mr sondheim and thank you for joining us
today as i understand that the review
board is interested in my opinions about
a number of issues related to the
exercise of the government's eminent
domain power its power to force private
individuals to give up property uh over
this camera original film of uh
taken by mr zapruder
especially the issue whether the records
collection act
affects a taking of the film for which
just compensation is due or whether it
authorizes the review board to affect
such a taking
and i'm going to direct my prepared
comments to that narrow issue the issue
of legal authorization
and then any other broader
issues that can be explored later in
questions
let me say at the beginning that
there's really not any
constitutional
question here under settled law uh
congress has eminent domain powers over
both real estate uh and personal
property
in the united states uh presumably
including the zapruder film
nor do i think that there's any question
that um
if the uh review board were to direct
the archives to place the film in the
jfk collection that that would
constitute a taking for which just
compensation is due
the issue rather is a statutory one and
that is
uh given that congress had the power to
exercise eminent domain did it do so or
did it authorize the board to do so
in the records collection act
and having closely examined the text of
the statute and the legislative history
of the statute my conclusion is that
this is a close call
there are arguments to be made on both
sides and therefore i think it would be
most helpful for me today to outline the
arguments on on either side and then
leave the difficult questions to you
um
let me first consider the
portions of the text and the legislative
history that weigh in favor of the
exercise of
eminent domain or of the taking of the
film
mr gunn has already covered some of this
material in his testimony
there are two major
operative provisions in the act they are
sections 5c1 and 5d3
they both use the terms assassination
record
and possession
section 5 c1
directs each government office to review
identify and organize each assassination
record in its custody or possession
for eventual transmission to the jfk
collection
uh section 5d3 directs the archives to
place in the jfk collection all
again assassination records which are in
its possession and which had been
publicly available in their entirety
without redaction
um
mr gunn has suggested that it's not
really a question before the board today
whether the zapruder film constitutes an
assassination record but i guess just to
add to that i think i'd point out that
uh we're a court
if a court were in the position of
having to decide this issue uh i think
that there is a very good chance uh that
it would find that the sapruder film is
indeed an assassination record
so uh putting aside for the moment other
provisions of the jfk act
these two operative provisions would
indeed seem to mandate the transmission
of the zapruder film to the jfk
collection
uh
the um
if the if the issue of whether it's an
assassination record is put to one side
the only other issue is uh is it
is it a was it in the custody or
possession of uh either the archives or
some other government agency and i think
uh there's a
pretty good argument to be made that it
was
uh so that's the that's the major part
of the text of the statute which weighs
in favor of the finding that the statute
has taken the film
the other major factor it seems to me uh
that weighs in favor of a taking
is the text of the act and particularly
all of the statements in the legislative
history of the act that disclose the
purpose
of the act
the senate report on the act notes that
in the eyes of the public each
investigation and inquiry into the
assassination of president kennedy
served to raise additional questions
about the assassination uh the senate
report states that the jfk act was a
result of the recognition by congress
and the executive branch that the
records related to the assassination of
president kennedy be fully disclosed
uh the zapruder film as has mr guns
already stated is such an important
record of the assassination
that it may well be the case that
failure to
maintain a government possession of the
camera original or to disclose it to the
public
might well undermine the public
confidence and there i'm quoting again
from the senate report um that it it
identifies as one of the underlying
principles of the act
so there's the there's the gist of the
case in favor of a taking
let me turn to the other side um
now however and look at the text and the
legislative history and an interpretive
principle that courts might apply uh
that way in the opposite direction
it seems to me having looked at the act
that the most important piece of text
may be section 11a of the act
section 11a creates an exception to
those operative provisions i was talking
about earlier
it creates an exception to this acts
requirement that all assassination
records in the possession of government
agencies
be transmitted to the jfk collection and
publicly disclosed
a section 11a in particular says that
the acts requirement will not apply when
it conflicts with and here i quote the
act deeds governing access to or
transfer or release of gifts and
donations of records to the united
states government
so in other words if someone has given
records to the federal government uh
they've placed certain restrictions on
them as to transfer of those records or
release of those records
the review board is directed by the act
to respect those restrictions
one could interpret this exception as a
result of a determination by congress
that when private individuals have
retained certain rights in records that
are in possession of the government the
act shouldn't be applied in such a way
as to violate or diminish those rights
now my understanding is that the
zapruder film was delivered to the
archives under a storage agreement that
gives its owners the right to retrieve
it from the archives
this storage agreement is not a deed
in the narrow sense of uh of deed within
section 11a which uh gives rise to sort
of another ambiguity that the board
would have to deal with
uh
although it's not a deed in the narrow
sense of that term it is an agreement
which grants limited rights to the
archives and which reserves rights in a
private grantor
indeed one might say it reserves greater
rights in the private grantor than a
restricted deed would
the jfk act also grants the review board
the power to issue regulations
interpreting the terms of the act
and i think it's likely that a court
would uphold
a broad interpretation of deed as
covering any instrument under which
possession of or title ii a record was
transferred to a government office so i
think if the review board were to uh
come to the conclusion that
it thought it um
appropriate uh to uh define deed broadly
that a court would probably uphold that
broad uh definition that of course would
mean then that the
review board would not be mandated by
the act to transfer uh this uh this the
pruder film to the um
jfk collection
um and significantly the uh the senate
report on the jfk act the uh the records
collection act states that if the review
board locates assassination records that
were given to the government subject to
restrictions
it should and here i quote the senate
report where possible seek the waiver or
necessary permission to open the records
to the american public
this language doesn't seem to complica
to contemplate a taking in which the
review board would force public
disclosure and pay just compensation to
the donors for breaking their
restrictions rather it seems only to
contemplate that the board would seek a
voluntary uh waiver of the restrictions
on the part of those
uh the donors
now aside from section 11a
the act also contains several references
to
government records
a term that shows up in a number of
provisions in the act which could be
read as suggesting that the act applies
only to records owned by the government
the term government records applies in
the findings and declarations portion of
the act and it also applies uh it also
appears in a number of its operative
provisions
uh and perhaps most significantly
section 4a1 of the act provides that the
jfk collection at the national archives
quote shall consist of record copies of
all government records relating to the
assassination of president john f
kennedy
government records however is an
undefined term in the act
uh and section 482 the immediately uh
subsequent section governing
describing in detail the contents of the
jfk collection says that that collection
will include all assassination records
that the act requires it to include
now the term assassination record of
course is defined uh and i think it does
not appear to require government
ownership
and my guess here is just that the term
government record is a remnant of an
earlier stage of the process of drafting
the act probably should have been wholly
replaced by assassination record uh and
one of the ways one might render various
portions of the act consistent would be
to interpret government record as
meaning any record in the possession of
the government not uh where title is
owned by the government
in addition to these two items of text
that the jfk act does contain
it might be notable that the act is
missing any reference to eminent domain
or just compensation uh and in this
respect one might contrast the act which
with the the so-called presidential
recordings and materials preservation
act uh the famous act concerning the
presidential papers and the tapes made
by president richard nixon
uh the this act the prnpa uh it's in its
uh acronym form it's similar in some
respects to the jfk act uh it also
requires any federal government employee
in possession of certain records here
relating to the nixon presidency
to deliver them to the archivist of the
united states
who's directed to retain those records
but the prnpa expressly recognizes that
the actions that it mandates may amount
to a taking for which just compensation
is required
there's a section in the pr mpa which
says
payment of just compensation shall be
made from the general fund of the united
states treasury
if a court holds that any provision of
the act has deprived an individual of
private property without just
compensation so
in the case of the pr mpa
closely similar operative provisions but
a clear indication from congress that it
realized a taking uh might be found
by contrast the jfk act of course
contains no provision suggesting that
congress contemplated
that the act might affect the taking
uh the legislative history of the act
reinforces the impression that congress
didn't contemplate that the act might
require the payment of just compensation
for example the senate report on the act
contains a section evaluating the
regulatory impact of the legislation
that section declares that the act i
quote would not result in any additional
regulation to any individuals and
businesses
unquote and therefore would have no
economic impact on any individuals or
businesses
the senate report also contains
an analysis undertaken by the
congressional budget office
with of the cost of implementing the act
and that cost estimate does not include
any amount for paying awards of just
compensation to individuals whose
private property is taken by the act
and then finally having
taken a look at the the text of the
statute in the legislative history uh
let me just point out one interpretive
presumption that courts use that may
also weigh in favor of a finding that
the act does not affect the taking
the supreme court has stated that the
power of eminent domain the power to
force private individuals to uh
give up their property a quote must be
given in express terms or by necessary
implication so it's a kind of rule that
says if you want to
use the power of eminent domain you have
to do it
clearly
it's possible to argue that if the jfk
act indeed mandates transfer of all
assassination records in government
hands
to the jfk collection
and there's a pruder film as an
assassination record
then we could say it is a necessary
implication that eminent domain power
will be exercised in making the transfer
if it turns out that this fruit or film
is private property
uh the canon however
or interpretive presumption
indicates that a court
if faced with equally balanced
conflicting evidence about whether a
statute directs actions that might or
might not
amount to attacking
would likely decide that the statute did
not require
such actions so in some there's support
on both sides of this takings issue
and i would for one would find it
difficult to predict exactly what a
court would do and i'm happy to answer
any questions that you might have
thank you professor brownies questions
members of the board
it's been a great interest this um
question of possession
and uh it may very well be for example
that the congress was not as aware
of the fact that the archive stores
things
and so uses the word possession
possession um
in your view then means
what does it mean that this food or film
may or may not because you just finished
saying that if it turns out that there's
the zapruder film
is not in the hands of the government
would is it your opinion then that the
film is or is not in the possession of
the possession of the federal of the
federal government uh i think it's uh
most likely that a court would find that
the film is in the possession of the
federal government um
it's uh it's not it's not in it's not
entirely the case that uh congress was
completely unaware uh i think that the
archive uh stores items uh although the
the material in the legislative history
is sort of
scant but the the um the archivist
did mention the deposit agreements in
the legislative history so
some evidence that that that congress
may have been aware of that
can you point to uh
presidents uh professor bronice where
the united states government has uh
taken
artifacts
so to speak from uh private individuals
using its imminent domain power
well i think uh the
the most famous uh recent example is uh
the um the act under which uh the um
nixon tapes and papers uh were taken
from uh president nixon and uh retained
by the government uh the
district of columbia uh circuit the
federal court
decided that indeed that act did
constitute a taking uh and ordered uh
that the government paid us compensation
for those records and those those were
tapes and papers and all sorts of things
uh that
uh pertained to the nixon administration
uh so that's a very clear example
recently of uh of the taking of
certainly a
larger bulk
of records than is involved here
go ahead
mr mr brown ice let me ask you would
this case
or this set of circumstances
be different if in fact the film were
not in the archives
oh i think i think it would i guess that
relates in part back to uh ms nelson's
question about possession uh
if the film were not in the archives
then there's much greater issue about
whether any of the operative provisions
in the act mandate the transmission of
the film to the jfk collection
it's not in the possession of any
government agency uh and um
i think it most likely under those
circumstances uh that um
the act would not mandate uh a
transmission fulfillment so the the
distinction with regard to possession
turns out
at least for purposes of thinking our
way through
the statutory understanding turns out to
be significant that's correct okay
is there anything in the legislative
history
that would suggest to you that those who
frame the statute
intended that the zabruder film be
exempted
from being included as an assassination
record
and i posed that question in the context
of at least in in one instance that with
regard to
the autopsy photographs they were fully
capable of designating a specific
category
there there's nothing in the legislative
history that specifically singles out
the zapruder film there's no mention of
the film by name uh that suggests that
um congress uh was thinking of exempting
it from the collection the
only
indication in the legislative history is
testimony
of the archivist of the united states
which may have
resulted in the um
the amendment uh uh the
the placement of section 11a in the act
the broader exception that i was talking
about earlier uh that exception
for restrictions in gift deeds was not
in the original drafts of the uh
of the act uh and the archivist
testified uh that um
failure to put such an exception
in the act uh would um
likely result in fewer donations uh
of of of records and therefore uh there
should be such an exception and one of
the archives position statements
actually mentions deposit agreements as
well as gift deeds
but as we know it section 11a only
refers to gift deeds well let me if i if
i may mr chairman press just a little
bit on on this particular issue
and raise with you the question of
whether or not section 11a
is directed at the question of how
materials that are in the possession of
can be used
and access granted and rights to be able
to view them would be structured between
the archives and a person who's making a
donation or contribution
as against the question of removal of
the material altogether from the
possession of the government and
returning it to the individual who
originally uh donated it
it's possible that uh
that congress did have in mind that that
sort of distinction uh section 11a
mentions
transfer as well as disclosure
uh so uh it they may have been concerned
about physically where the items were uh
but um
it it certainly is the case that if the
item was indeed donated
to the federal government then when we
presume that it remains in the
possession of the federal government and
as you say the issue is simply where is
it in the government's possession
when will it be disclosed and to whom
under what conditions
one final question if i may and and that
is um
if if i could
and i'm not sure this is appropriate
that's really where i need your help the
law professor's help here
um what if we what if we took our
understanding of this issue
and did not see it initially as a
question of taking our imminent domain
although that might matter may well
enter into the discussion at some other
point
but viewed it rather as a question of
bailment
that is uh the zapruders had given the
film to the archives the archives are
acting in the capacity of a bailly
in
in the set of circumstances that were
governed by then existing rules
the rules however in the course of the
time that the material were held was
held the bailment arrangement had
changed
would it not be possible then that the
archives would find itself in some
conflict
and that it might and the government
might well in that capacity of acting as
a bailly act in favor of
of retaining the material
given the fact that it is not private in
the strict sense of the word but rather
is in fact in possession and it's now
become an assassination record and
therefore the archives could do what it
did
which is to say we're not going to
return the material because we cannot do
that in our capacity uh acting in this
bail availment capacity i think in fact
that's the other side of section 11a uh
section 11a is titled rules of
construction and it says uh that uh the
mandates uh in the other operative
provisions of the act
shall supersede any other statute and
any other common law doctrine
and that's the doctrine of bailment
that
that might direct and government agency
to do something different and the only
exception that it makes is for gift
deeds that have certain restrictions in
them
so
if section 11a on the one hand opens up
this possibility of
deed on the other hand it sort of
forecloses other possibilities and says
common law doctrines shall not take
precedence over this act
okay thank you very much
mr chairman uh if i might ask professor
brown eyes
to come back to the point that uh
judge toonheim was on before
um
about
whether there's a precedent for
the
handling of something like this
was this film
transmuted into an assassination
record and therefore
did it become like a document in the
nixon case or is there something unique
about this
um like the liberty bell or
betsy ross's flag or what
that requires a special kind of legal
treatment
i don't think uh that uh
the act uh certainly has anything to say
about uh
its liberty bell status as affecting um
its legal status the act of course uh
defines assassination record very
broadly to include
not only
paper but films sound recordings and so
on uh and the zapruder film may not be
the only
uh record within that definition that
has gained some sort of iconic status
over the years uh
so i don't i don't really see um
we have not identified another with this
kind of iconic status
right
uh
i suppose my answer remains the same
though i don't i don't really see that
um
that particular
aspect
changes things legally
professor brownise
is there any support for the proposition
that the legislation in designating
assassination records as including
all exhibits before the warren
commission
and since the supruder film was shown to
the warrant commission
is there any support for the proposition
that it is already an assassination
record by the passage of the act
oh i think that's uh that's quite
possible yeah uh the
of course uh the
act
also grants the power to
the board to define uh the terms
of the act and you have uh taken that
power and defined the assassination
record
there
may well be outer limits uh to that
power though and if you were to attempt
to use your power to define
assassination records so narrowly
that it excluded the supruder film or
excluded other records that came
before the assassination before the
warrant commission
that a court might find that you had
exceeded the scope of your delegated
powers under
under the act that
when it gave you some leeway to define
terms it didn't give you leeway to say
that a horse was a cow
so just to clarify that issue a little
bit more
is it possible to argue the act has
already effectuated a taking of this
particular
artifact and therefore there is
essentially no decision before the board
i think it is that's right i think it is
uh i think it is and to go back again
there is a distinction to be drawn here
between a film
of the assassination that reposes or is
is in repose
in the refrigerator of the archives and
a film that's held in someone's
desk
in dubuque i think that's a very
important distinction
of course the zapruder
the lmh company that could
of course challenge this view
in which case it would then be taken to
the court of claims
that's correct
presumably um
it's it seems to me that uh
well it's an interesting thought that um
the act has already decided this issue
for us
is that really what you meant i mean we
keep pushing that because
that of course um is a very interesting
new idea that you've brought in today
uh that that is really what i meant yeah
the uh again as i suggest the although
the act gives the power to the review
board to
issue interpretive regulations a court
might find that there are limits to that
power
and if
uh if the uh if the film is an
assassination record in that was in the
possession of certain government
agencies then the act just says it shall
be transmitted to the jfk collection and
it was a part of the warren commission
that's correct
i'm going to ask you one last question
uh professor brown is uh
you've examined uh a lot of cases in
which uh
takings have occurred and in which
courts have determined value eventually
for the
material that was taken
any thoughts you have for us on what the
financial costs to the taxpayers might
be in a case like this one
well the measure of damages or the
measure of just compensation generally
is fair market value is that food
commercial value that certainly does
it's what the property would bring on
the open market if it were say put up
for an auction
uh so um
that's the measure of damages i
certainly can't speculate as to
what that would be there are other
appraisal experts i'm sure who
would have their say about that i
suppose the only one other thing i might
mention is that there could be a
separate value uh and perhaps mr gunn
has already adverted to this could be a
separate value placed on the physical
object itself
the camera original film and other
rights associated with that film such as
copyright
and so you might
might easily place
one component of fair market value as a
fair market value of the original as an
artifact the other component is other
rights such as copyright
just one quick question in pursuance of
that
if is there precedent
for a taking to
transfer a title but to leave copyrights
and other rights similar to that with
the original owner
i have uh i have not come across a case
in which that's been done
but i would not find it uh all out of
the ordinary given uh the structure of
copyright law which presumes that
copyright is completely separate set of
rules than the rules about title over
the physical object
thank you very much professor brown i
think we appreciate your joining us
today very good
next we're going to hear from jim lasar
who is the president of the
assassination archives and research
center welcome mr lazar
good afternoon mr chairman whoops
members of the panel we're happy to have
you back again to advise us today it's a
pleasure to be here
um
this
the questions that the board has asked
are
revolving around eminent domain are not
really within my expertise
so i faced them with some trepidation
particularly after listening to press
professor
brownis's
very scholarly exposition
pointing up all of the
aspects of the statutory language that
bear
on the questions
i
would uh
i have a somewhat different take on a
couple of matters
that may have some bearing on
the ultimate issues
first i think that
while it's important always to analyze
the bits and pieces of a statute
that
those bits and pieces have to be
considered
in light of the
overarching purpose of the statute
and the jfk act
was clearly intended
to
accomplish a couple of things that are
set
forth in
section two of the act
findings declarations and purposes
and the very first
finding declaration and purpose is that
congress found that all government
records related to the assassination of
president john f kennedy
should be preserved for historical and
governmental purposes
i think it's very important that
the board take actions consistent
with that purpose and and not lose sight
of the forest here
i also
have
a thought regarding
whether or not the jfk act has
already effected
a taking
and it's my view
that
with respect to the copyright
in the film
that the jfk act has in fact affected a
taking
by virtue of the very section
that the professor has cited
section 11 a
which provides that uh
the jfk act in effect overrides
um all prior statutes the
jfk act having been passed subsequent to
the copyright act
i think that it overrides the copyright
act and so
the congress has itself affected the
taking
of the copyright
now that has implications certainly for
the value of the film because the value
of the commercial value of the film
is
hardly separable from
the copyright in the film
and it also has implications in terms of
public access because
under both the jfk and the free freedom
of information act
if it is an assassination record and i
think unquestionably it is
then
the
public
has a right to have copies
of the film
certainly at no more than cost and in
under the waiver provisions of both acts
the public may also in certain instances
be able to get them without costs
so that leaves you with a question of
the
the
value of the actual physical copy
the camera original as divorced from the
copyright and it seems to me one that
that value is
greatly diminished
certainly is important to have it in in
the collection for for various reasons
the jfk act section 4 of the jfk act
also provides that
the arc archivist in establishing the
collection
is to ensure the physical integrity
uh and provenance
of all
records
i think it is
difficult if not impossible to ensure
the integrity of the film
and
its provenance so long as it remains
subject to the women caprice of private
ownership
so
i would
argue that and it seems to me also
um
somewhat ludicrous to argue that
congress did not intend the most
important and the unique piece of
evidence
to be in the collection to be fully
accessible
to the public
and
i think it needs to be
subject to government ownership
in order to
not only to preserve it
but to make sure that with advances in
technology
the public
may have access to the information
information provided by any
advances in technology that can take
place
so
um
now as to uh one other there's a there
are various scenarios as to how this
matter could resolve itself um
i have suggested that in fact the
act has already effectuated the taking
and the implication of that is that
someone who wanted to put that to the
test can file suit under the freedom of
information and jfk acts
and seek a court resolution of it
there there have been previous
attempts to ensure that the zapruder
film
uh
be made part of the public dialogue on
the kennedy assassination
and that history is first in the barnard
geist associates case which i think
professor tink thompson will uh josiah
thompson will
inform you about later uh the court
ruled
that it was said that the copies that he
made of it for use in his book six
seconds in dallas were subject to the
fair use doctrine
secondly professor
melville nimmer
a
noted
copyright scholar
and first amendment scholar
proposed that in certain a very certain
narrow class of cases
the first amendment
interest in enlightened democratic
dialogue
overrides the copyright interest
he gave two examples of that one the
example of the famous
photographs of the milai massacre
the second
the zapruder film
and
in his opinion it would be
unconscionable that
the copyright interest would supersede
the overwhelming public interest
that could not be fulfilled in any other
way
but through access to
the
to the the photographs
i think that um
if i'm correct if the
uh
jfk act has effectuated
uh an expropriation of the copyright
then
it would seem bizarre to hold
that congress did not also intend
that the original
camera original would not be in the
possession of a government
for one thing it would mean that
future requesters would not be able to
take advantage of advances in technology
to request the
newly available information
um
those are basically my thoughts i'll be
happy to answer any questions if i can
let me ask you a question uh mr lazar
you were active in the
passage of this act and testified before
the congress
quite active as i recall
why don't you think
the congress specifically mentioned the
eminent domain issue
in the act
i have no idea i had an input into the
act but not into that part of it
i can only say that
when i saw section 11 my immediate
reaction was
that takes care of the zapruder film
um
mr lazar you heard we all heard
professor brown eyes
say that um
acknowledge that quite likely
the court of claims would have to hear a
case that the lmh company would in fact
probably
seek
money
seek
payment and so part of our task is to
perhaps be decide how much in fact the
american people
will be out
taxpayers will be out if we in fact
decide to keep to take the film
under any of these conditions say it is
part of the act anyway
what how far up would you as a
as someone who has had the
assassinations
resources so many of the documents
how high should we go
that is to say
it's difficult to compare but we know
for example that
bill gates paid about 20 million dollars
for the leonardo
codex
how far should
should we go
making it making now making an
assumption here
that we that it is not already included
i'm making a different kind of
assumption
um
i don't know i don't
one
i'm not um
familiar enough with the calculations
that
would go into that to make a very very
good guess as as to it i
as a
more as a personal reaction than as a
a legal matter
i would think that
the
fair market value should be offset by
the
very large sums of monies that have been
paid out in the past and i must say that
what particularly troubles me about the
exercise which i view is a misuse of the
copyright with respect to this film
over the past decades
is that
it has in a i think if thwarted the
intent of the copyright provision in the
constitution which i view as ordinarily
intended to be consistent with the first
amendment
for 12 years after the assassination
[Music]
the american public did not get to see
this film and that had a devastating
impact
on the history of the case delaying its
reinvestigation among other things by
more than a decade
so i would i would hope that there'd be
some recognition that that the copyright
holder
has already
garnered an enormous windfall profit
from this film and would not put the
taxpayers to
any further great expenditure of funds
what what would your uh what would your
estimation be of the uh on the amounts
that those recruiters have
have earned uh from the copyright
well i would say that it it probably uh
would approach a million dollars is my
guess we start with 150 000 that we know
about for certain there's
there have been movie producers that
have paid reportedly 30 or 40 000
there have been television producers and
others
so i would not be surprised if it
approached that figure
but i have no personal knowledge of it i
think that that is
something that the review board should
try and find out uh uh if it has to um
to make a determination as to how much
should be paid for the film let me uh if
i may
kind of follow up on that and follow the
context of anna's question
um would it be your judgment that uh
that um
and let's assume for purposes of
argument that the copyright issue is not
settled in the way that you believe it
should be
is there any um
is there any ceiling
on what the american people should pay
i think there's obviously a ceiling
there's a ceiling to everything
short of
national survival but uh
where that ceiling is i don't know
but well certainly one of the important
that is a an an interesting and
important issue here and so is the
question of what researchers and
scholars might
take from
the zapruder film either in manners of
research or matters of authenticity
given the controversy that surrounds the
film
can you speculate for us at all about
what we what what it might mean to a
researcher to have this original
available well i think it means a great
deal to the research community i mean
remember that i cited some of the the
findings of the purpose of this act
but
perhaps the overriding purpose of the
act was to restore some confidence in
government
it's very difficult for me to see how
you can go to the assassination
community and say we have restored
confidence in the ability of the
government to come to grips with this
history and yet we are leaving the most
single most important piece of evidence
in the hands of a private citizen
that seems to me just to be uh
self-defeating it can't be it can't be
done but the crux of that understanding
would be that that a high quality copy
or a copy made of the
of the zebruder film before it got into
trouble at time life
uh would not be as good as the original
um
well there are other there it's not only
the question of the col the quality of
the original it's what happened to the
original splicings uh that were that
took place uh
there's a history to the original that
um
that is important and let me let me just
allude to one other thing the the act
says it is not only
it refers to
preserving it for historical and
governmental purposes now of course
the odd thing about this film is that it
was not not seized by the government at
the start
this is a criminal case back the
criminal case of the highest magnitude
and
evidence is routinely seized in criminal
cases
and
that was not done here
but if i remember my legal precedence
well the rule of the rule with regard to
seizure and maintenance of evidence is a
function of act of having a criminal
proceeding
well that and and the fact that there
wasn't is a consequence of oswald having
been shot
but
the there is still the possibility
remote may though it may be that at some
point there will be a criminal
proceeding and then this provision
that preserves it for governmental
purposes takes precedence it's
inconceivable to me that at that point
the government would not assert its
interest
in the original i mean the court rules
require originals record copies and
there is a pro also a provision in the
in the act that refers to record copies
uh the obligation to preserve record
copies the zakruder film the cabinet
original is the ultimate record copy in
this case but if in if uh 20 years or 25
years from now there's nothing there
what
what
would anyone have any interest in the
zapruder film if in fact
the uh
the images that are there now if it
completely deteriorates into an
amorphous mass i suppose the answer is
no right so it could look like a bad
deal to pay out a lot of money to uh to
lay claim to something that will not
exist in the future
that that that's certainly a
consideration thank you
too i like to follow the related path um
you mentioned in the course of your
statement that you thought it was
important to preserve the film against
the development of future technological
advances that could assist us
understanding the event and i'm
wondering
if you could um
given your knowledge of the concerns and
the issues that are
in the research community if you could
tell us what kinds of information or
what questions are currently
focused on the film as a piece of
evidence concerning the assassination
and how future
developments might assist researchers
understand the event well
um
as to the the technological aspects i
it's beyond my kin i i'm
not
a photographer or
uh and i'm not very well versed in
computer science
so i do not know what the uh potentials
are with respect to
computer enhancement and and other
matters i would suggest that you you
might solicit the views of experts in
those uh those
my question really was aimed at the
questions the researchers would like to
have answers well there one one obvious
thing which was alluded to by mr gunn in
his present presentation is the
material between the sprocket holes
and uh about 20 of the exposed surface
of the original film
falls between the sprocket holes it is
not reproduced on
the
film copies of the original however it
can be reproduced through slides
so it requires the original in order to
capture
that information and that i think is
certainly a priority in the research
community is
is having a high quality copy
made of the camera original that will
pre
reproduce
the material between the sprocket holes
so that's one now there are other issues
which i'm less familiar with but i i
hear rumblings of them
in the hinterlands about questions about
authenticity of the film and alterations
of the film and so forth
i'm not really qualified to speak about
those
one final question mr lazar
your point that you made earlier that
any award of financial costs for
taking of this film
should be offset by the costs that the
family has made off the film and i
understand that completely from a
visceral kind of reaction are you aware
of any cases that would establish that
principle that we can no look again i
i'm not however i haven't had
any uh chance to research the issue but
i'm not aware of any okay
returning to professor joyce's question
there some of the other
the questions are the obvious ones that
relate to the sequence and timing of
shots
direction of shots
the
where the wounds are located
the movements of
witnesses um the movements and reactions
of secret service personnel
dallas police department personnel all
those things are of interest to the
research community
thank you mr lazar we appreciate your
testimony thank you very much
next we're going to hear from mr josiah
thompson who is an author
one of the early authors of a widely
read book on the assassination
six seconds in dallas i believe
mr thompson thank you for joining us
today
thank you mr chairman uh dr marwell
distinguished members of the panel
i do not have a prepared statement but
sitting here i've had a few thoughts
on two
basic points
one concerns the anomalies
concerning this film in private hands
which i had much experience of in the
1960s and 70s
and secondly
a question that was just asked what is
the central enormous
research importance of this film i could
and i will
give you some reasons for seeing the
centrality of the film
friday afternoon november 22nd and
forest sorrels is in abraham zapruder's
office
abraham zapruder gets his camera out of
the safe had forrest sorrell said mr
zapruder i'm taking that camera and that
film as evidence in this homicide
we might still be here today but we
wouldn't be here with this particular
problem
forrest earls did not do that i think he
made a mistake and because he did not do
that in august of 1966
when i came to this very building
and saw the zapruder film for the first
time
what i was permitted to see
was a copy of a secret service copy
in the summer of 1966 that was the only
way any ordinary citizen in this country
could see a copy of the zapruder film
was coming to the archives registering
and have marian johnson
screen a copy of a copy for you
i did that it was a miserable copy a
miserable copy
i had heard through the grapevine
that life's original and life's copies
made from that original four by five
transparencies were remarkably clear
through
brute luck
two years later two months later i ended
up being hired to co-direct life
magazine's assassination investigation
and was permitted to see
copies made from the original four by
five transparencies made from the
original
everything i'd been told was correct
they were remarkably clear
one could see the hit on conley which
was completely unclear on the copy in
the archives
dallas november 1966
we have four by five transparencies
the life team is made up of three or
four members
one of those members ends up either
stealing or destroying for those frames
very very important frames as a young
professor of philosophy i had not a clue
what was going on but i knew something
was going on
um
so three weeks later
i snuck a camera into the time life
building and made a copy of this pruder
film against specific orders of my
employer life magazine did that for two
reasons
the film was in private hands in private
custody
i figured i had no idea what was going
on at life magazine figured it was a
power struggle of some sort and thought
for posterity for all of us it would be
very useful to have a copy outside those
private hands
in addition i wanted to make certain
measurements on the film concerning the
movement of the president's head
measurements that were finally published
in uh six seconds which would give some
notion as to whether impressed forces on
the president at the time of the head
shot
could be interpreted
as either one shot or two shots i was
not permitted to take the film out of
the building hence to do that i had to
make a copy
i had to steal a copy
following june uh we made an offer to
time inc my publisher i made an offer
which was we would turn over all
commercial interest in the book to
timing in exchange for the right to use
selected parts of certain zapruder
frames
we were turned down flat and on advice
of council went forward and published
artist renderings of those films we were
sued i lost all the earnings of the book
but we won
uh judge insert b wyatt of the southern
district ruled in a summary judgment
that we had used the film as a fair use
that particular judgment mentioned by
jim lazar
was in fact an enormously important
expansion of the doctrine of fair use
where first amendment
privileges involved
that's the way things stood in other
words what i'm trying to explain here is
that with the film in private hands all
sorts of anomalies occurred
uh the necessity of me trying to act for
the public good to steal a copy of the
film which is a rather extraordinary
event
why is this film important it's
enormously important if you want to know
what happened in dealey plaza this film
shows you as much as any film can
how could it be used by the research
community well
there have been certain quibbles about
the authenticity of these of this film i
have no doubt that it's it's authentic
but that can be proven that can be shown
all
queries and challenges to the
authenticity if this film is in
government hands remains in government
hands can be
satisfactorily overcome
when that's done
this film then becomes a baseline for
all additional studies of what happened
in delhi plaza for example
uh the medical evidence there have been
many claims of of extra autopsies faking
of autopsy photos etc etc if the medical
evidence does not match what you see on
the zapruder film
then you might have cause to challenge
that sort of evidence evidence of other
films could be compared against this
film as a baseline if they match fine if
they don't match you know that
something's wrong
much more importantly of course is the
deduction of trajectories and ultimately
firing points which can only be done
with great precision by using the most
uh resolved copy of the film available
all of that can be done only if this
film remains in government hands
in 1964
j hoover said this case would be forever
open
in
1977 78 the house committee judged that
a conspiracy was involved in the kennedy
assassination was in fact probable
um
we now know that
the case really is still open at this
time
and as jim lazar pointed out there may
be a federal prosecution in the future
for all those reasons the central
evidence in the case
should remain in government hands as it
is now
and uh the legal arguments i think that
mr lazar and the professor uh offered uh
should sustain you in your judgment to
take the film
thank you mr thompson are there
questions
i i have a question for you
in terms of the
future
needs and uses
of this film by researchers do you think
that
copies made now cut particularly copies
that might be
the the complete frame including the
sprocket copies that are digitalized
do you think that serves the same
purpose for the for the sake of
researchers who are examining this film
assuming that uh you can guarantee that
they do come from the original
yes i don't think any researchers should
be
fiddling around with the original
i think there should be a protocol
established
as for how a digitized copy is made with
the
state-of-the-art equipment
state-of-the-art techniques
state-of-the-art algorithms etc that
digitized copy which is then fully
authenticated should then be the basis
of all research in the future
the original would simply be held as a
kind of reference mark that would
continually be available to justify
the copy as a foundational copy
go ahead
you seem to water down a little bit in
in your last statement i realized that
you don't have a piece of paper in front
of you
the importance of holding on to the
original suppose you had a
team saying this is an accurate
true copy of the original
why would the possession of the original
then
by the government
be essential well because we don't know
whether the techniques that we use
tomorrow and the protocols and
algorithms we would use tomorrow to make
the the most highly resolved copy we can
make
we don't know that five years from now
we can't do better or ten years from now
do better
thank you
and with respect to the question that uh
dr hall uh asked mr lazar
uh is there a ceiling on the amount that
the taxpayers should pay for this film
in your view
i don't think the taxpayers should pay a
penny for this
uh
i should add that the figure 150 000
which the zapruder family received from
life magazine i know from working at
life did not include the licensing
rights
life then
sold the sold the zapruder film to their
stern to
parry match etc etc
the zapruder family also had an interest
in those licensing rights so uh
i have no idea whether jim lazar's
estimate as under a million dollars is
is accurate in my opinion it could run
as far as three to five million at this
point
thank you very much mr thompson we
appreciate your joining us today
next we're going to hear from moses
weitzman uh who is a photographic expert
who has worked with the zapruder film in
the past good afternoon mr weissman
thank you for joining us
much of what i was going to say probably
has already been voiced by the previous
witnesses
my understanding of my testimony was to
comment on the technical value of
keeping the original and i believe there
are several good reasons for keeping the
original under archive control
as already mentioned technology is
advancing exponentially in the future we
will have better capability of
duplicating at analyzing the images both
photochemically and digitally
the copies that i made for time life was
done 30 years ago
even today's technology
is well ahead there are better lenses
film
and computerized digital scanning
because of the last mentioned item
digital scanning which would enable
someone to accurately record but also
unfortunately to manipulate the image
it would be important to keep the
original as a benchmark
of accuracy to guard against
irresponsible manipulations of the image
one of the uh i believe with mr lazar
mentioned something about the
information between the sprocket holes
unfortunately when i did the work 30
years ago there was no equipment for
duplicating eight millimeter we
jury rigged existing hardware
and the way i came to be recommended to
do it was by the manufacturer of the
equipment oxford corporation
that imagery could very well be
duplicated by properly manufactured
components
and
if the material were to be retained by
the archive and i would recommend them
doing so it would be well for them to
invest in the hardware which would be
nominal when all things are considered
to properly duplicate this material with
today's technology both photochemically
and digitally
there are several very fine companies on
the west coast making motion pictures
which are reaping multi-millions which
i'm sure would leap at the opportunity
to assist the committee in doing a
better job of this
and i
would welcome any questions i guess that
presentation's it
go ahead henry um mr wiseman when did
you last see the film
uh
i think i saw it for a second time uh
when i believe it was cbs and brought it
to me for duplicating i think it was an
anniversary of the assassination
possibly 1975.
so we
you don't do well i do yourself know
from observation what the condition of
the film well today i
um i was here about six or seven months
ago
and here in the archives here at the
archive i don't remember whether i was
shown the film or not but my
recollection of it was in 75 that it was
in less condition than it was when i
first saw it
and uh with all things
that are not made of stone they will
deteriorate with time but preservation
of film is a fine art today and eastman
kodak has put out many many such papers
it's been my personal experience they
even reclaimed a piece of footage that
the emulsion was peeling away from the
substrate
so
there is there is certainly the
possibility of maintaining the film it's
approximately 30 some odd years
you could keep film for a hundred years
if it's properly maintained
thank you
well that was it was really
the heart of my question as well and
that is
is this truly a wasting asset
well everything everything
everything sooner or later deteriorates
and disappears but i would think for our
practical
purposes i would think that you could
maintain this film at least for another
25 to 50 years which would probably
serve the purpose well because by then
the technology as i mentioned which is
advancing exponentially will enable us
no doubt to record it
with permanent accuracy that is not
available today
and
my original contention is that it should
be kept as a benchmark so that in the
near future if someone starts to
manipulate the image and put things in
there that really aren't supposed to be
there there will be something that says
hey this is what the original was there
isn't xyz person out there in the front
do you know how many copies there are of
this recruiter oh god
unfortunately i probably am the
grandfather of many of them
i the original copy that that
the original copy the very first copy i
made was a 16 millimeter film
which i showed the time life they were
very very excited about that they
commissioned us to make a 35 millimeter
copy
since there did not exist any proper
equipment the very first copy i made in
35 millimeter
was substandard commercially it was
placed
incorrectly
the the track area of the film so it
could not be used that was thrown into a
box in my office i was general manager
and quality control and vice president
of a company
i left the company shortly thereafter
and was then recalled by the
owners of the company technical
animations
to sell off the assets they wanted us
they close the company down
and lo and behold in my office there was
my box with that piece of film that
technically imperfect
copy and the best of my knowledge that
copy is what a great many copies have
been made from
i kept it as a sample of my expertise
not
not being into the whole
uh
underground culture of the zapruder
pardon me part of your portfolio so to
speak yes what i could do like you know
drawing a perfect circle so to speak
and that's what i periodically would
trotted out to show it to people
i presume at some point because it was
not i didn't keep it under lock and key
somebody made surreptitious copies of it
and then use it well it seems to me if
you're if you're concerned about
baseline issues that having some sense
of the uh
spread
breadth of
copies that are out there becomes very
very important
thank you
for me
mr weitzman to return to your comment
about the importance of preserving the
film as a baseline
i'm wondering
are you absolutely confident that uh you
on the basis of the knowledge that you
have both of the original film and the
technology and filmmaking and film
reproduction today that you could
authenticate the original
film in the camera as the original film
uh let me understand the question are
you asking me whether at the time i did
it initially did i know it was the
original film no i'm asking you if if we
were to
take
if the film were to be taken today
and one of the important considerations
does seem to me to be your thought about
the baseline which other people i think
jim lazar mentioned that as well
are you confident that the film can be
authenticated as the original camera
copy of the film certainly eastman kodak
could it was kodachrome and there might
be i don't remember precisely but i
believe there were edge markings on the
film as to when it was manufactured
and they certainly could could make uh
forensic
examination of it when the material was
laid down as to whether it's a piece
that would be photographed originally
yes you'd look at it and if the image
reads through the base we know it came
from from a
an original camera
as to whether it would be a reaper it
would be impossible to make a duplicate
contact copy reading through the base
today someone might have a hard hardware
to make a a an image reading through the
bass optically that is to say through a
lens but if one were to make a contact
copy immediately you'd see the
difference it would not be proper to
also read the wrong way so there are
there are a lot of ground rules that one
could determine a it's an original that
was photographed in a camera and b it
wasn't made by a contact copy
and
the manufacturer could give you a good
good indication of when this particular
piece of film was manufactured
i've been interested in what you were
telling us because
we have heard that the film
was really no longer viewable
that it had disintegrated and i think
part of the problem was that in the
earliest period when time life had it
probably didn't have quite the same
facilities that the national archives
has
and just to make sure i understand what
you're saying is that really doesn't
matter anymore no matter how bad off the
film is
something can be done with it and can be
revive it can restore it
unless the image is totally destroyed
and i don't know no i don't think so i
don't know that answer it because the
process of duplicating it is a on a
frame by frame basis on equipment uh at
least the equipment that i had used uh
an optical printing machine which looks
like a motion picture projector
sitting on a lathe bed facing a very
precise camera focusing on the image and
photographing it is advanced at a frame
at a time
also one would use what is called a full
immersion gate that is kind of an
aquarium that each individual frame is
surrounded by a liquid that has the same
refractive index as the emulsion that
would remove a good deal of the of the
damage
if it were being scanned rather than
being put on to film but scanned
digitally then that image could be
enhanced and
repaired so to speak as many most modern
motion pictures are being done for
commercial re-release so
unless the material is really really
destroyed
it can be brought to
near pristine condition that's an
important consideration for us
there there is however uh mr weitzman
in the evidence that some of the frames
from the original are missing
uh through handling at some point in
time and it's in its past
uh that together with the
uh the
somewhat deteriorated condition that the
film is in is there any argument that
first generation copies may today be
better evidence of the original than the
original itself
well
certainly
certainly a copy should be undertaken
now with today's technology it's better
than what i had 30 years ago no question
about it
and i think if that were to be done
someone should invest 10 or 15 or 20 000
that's necessary for the additional
hardware to duplicate regular eight
millimeter with a full immersion gate
the missing frames were missing when i
got the material
because that was part of what it is
however if there exists those frames
elsewhere even if they aren't very good
they could be reinserted and enhanced
so you could reconstruct a digital copy
that in some ways might be better than
the original but nevertheless the
original would still be the benchmark
because one would assume that this is
being done by responsible people
and being held under responsible uh
circumstances
help me a little bit here
there are in fact copies of this pruder
film
that predate
the taking of those frames or those
so there there is in fact a copy that
contains
those pre those now missing
frames in the original right
now i guess the question that i would
pose then
and this is this in the area of
speculation etc etc would it not be the
case that that copy
would have
for evidentiary purposes
because it is pristine in the sense that
it has not been chopped up greater value
no sir because it's a contact copy in my
understanding that is to say it's an
eight millimeter that was made not
optically with a lens but by contact a
sandwich
and as a result of that fine detail was
lost
all right so the
so the argument the argument then would
be
that uh
that previous copy the full copy that is
with the frames in it is of value but it
doesn't in your judgment uh transcend
the necessity of having the original as
a baseline that's correct sir thank you
we've heard arguments over time that
there's the there is the ability to
enhance the original to make it into a
sharper
make make
a better film out of it
is that true i mean can you take
take the film today and and enhance it
or are we simply creating new issues
where there weren't issues before
yes there is that capability i'm not an
expert in computer uh technology i have
a passing understanding of it because
it's now a technology that is coming to
fruition after i retired
however
from the literature that i've read the
answer to that question is yes you can
take an unsharp image and sharpen it
there's there are algorithms that will
determine where the edges meet so to
speak of a light in a dark area and
create a new uh a new image you can even
well you've seen it in motion pictures
jurassic park and uh
any number of them where they uh they
create and paint full images
so
that but unfortunately that very
capability would enable someone who is
irresponsible to paint in something that
doesn't exist so the necessity of
keeping that that that joe block or that
meter block
in in
archive is very very important so this
baseline argument then really turns out
to be important not just in terms of
gauging other copies but taking account
of what might be done with the original
if it were put in private hands exactly
to some way to distort uh and put on
copies you know sensational exploitation
needless to say everyone here has been
exposed to that sort of thing
twister
uh thank you very much mr weissman we
appreciate your testimony today
next we're going to hear from richard
trask who is a photographic expert on
the
photography of the assassination and has
written a book entitled pictures of the
pain and we welcome your presence here
today mr trask good to see you again
thank you
well i have some prepared remarks which
i'm going to
cut down a bit for the sake of time
there's both a pleasure and an honor to
be before the board again
after i spoke with you back in march
1995
during your hearings to obtain public
input on the scope of your work i was
most pleased that you actively included
photographic records within your purview
i believe that the diverse assassination
research community and the broader
community of american historians almost
universally applaud your efforts
and tenacity to locate and make
available any and all records relating
directly and indirectly to the
assassination of president kennedy i
also want to tell you how how impressed
i have been by the professionalism
objectiveness and commitment of david
marwell
and the staff with whom i have come into
contact uh particularly tom semelek with
whom i have spoken and worked on a
number of occasions
i've been asked to comment today upon
the significance of the zapruder film
of the president kennedy assassination
particularly with regards to how the
film fits into the historical record of
the event
though i'm not a specialist on
photographic technology i spent over 10
years researching the photographic
history of the assassination as to the
story of the photographers and their
experiences the visual images they
created and how these images have been
used and abused by the government media
and critic
my wife and i self-published a
book in 1994 titled pictures of the pain
photography and the assassination of
president kennedy
historical photography is typically
defined as the use of photographic
images to facilitate the study and
interpretation of history
photography has limitations for use as
historical evidence however and may
exhibit only partial truths biases and
distortions of reality it can never tell
the whole story of an event and one must
cautiously realize its limits
yet for all the potential shortcomings
photography comes closer than any other
record to being a true trace of reality
while eyewitnesses accounts
of events can be accurate their accuracy
is skewed by the emotional impact
of the event upon the witness the
location of the witness to the event
personal bias
the later opinions of others and
recollections over time
though the medium of photography through
the medium of photography however
a photographer captures on film and a
form truer than any person's eye
or memory
brief
relevant and dramatic slices of the
reality of the scene and these created
images are able to be examined and
interpreted as true historical artifacts
of the incident itself
at d lee plaza on november 22 1963
about three dozen people had cameras
these incidental observers of history
recorded in a variety of photographic
formats and with differing equipment and
skills the last moments in the life of a
president
of the united states one of the most
famous photographers there was abraham
zapruder
around noon time zapruder walked a short
distance to the dele plaza park area he
noticed a rectangular block some four
feet high at the west end of the
decorative concrete pergola area
this location would afford him an
elevated perch giving him a good
sweeping view of elm street
the complete elm street motorcade
sequence which the pruda filmed runs
about 26 seconds the 486 frames all
later subsequently assigned individual
numbers for investigative references
had been exposed through zapruder's
telephoto camera lens at 18.3 frames per
second the first 132 frames was shot of
the lead motorcycle escort and when
zapruder started his camera again for an
approximately 19 second uninterrupted
run his first frame showed the
presidential lincoln already on elm
street
to cause the prudus film remarkable
is an exaggerated understatement it is
due to the subject matter and clear
angle of view undoubtedly one of the
most important if not the most
historically important movie film ever
made noted researcher josiah thompson
correctly described the zapruder film to
you today and in his uh
1967 book as quote the nearest thing to
absolute truth about the sequence of the
events in delhi
plaza end quote
we watch as the president and governor
react to shots
uh being made through their bodies
followed by a short sequence in which
mrs kennedy leans forward
and holds the arm of the president the
next is a terrible scene as the
president's head explodes like a ragdoll
he crumples into his seat
while his wife scurries out towards the
car trunk this amateur home movie almost
not made in the first place soon became
one of the most well-known artifacts of
the 20th century
though this strip of film shows us in
excruciating decay detail the fact that
a president died it also up into immense
speculation the interpretation of the
exact means of his death
had the zapruder film never been taken
much of the later debate over the actual
sequence of shots the timing of the
shots and the victims reactions to the
shots would not have taken place
it is a dichotomy that's that much of
these later controversies surrounding
the facts of the assassination found
birth and this the very piece of
evidence that brought us the most
truthful
visual record of the assassination
itself
as a result of the film's existence
various government agencies and a
subculture of investigators have delved
into science pseudoscience studying
physics ballistics medicine pathology
human reaction to stimuli and photo
interpretation
all to find the truth of the reality
during the afternoon of november 22nd
zapruder had his film developed and then
had three first generations copies made
later that day the dallas
secret service was given custody of two
of the copies of the film
these prints were subsequently used by
the fbi and secret service
in the government's investigation
the existence and potential
newsworthiness of this film soon became
known to the media life magazine editor
bridget stolle arrived in dallas by the
end of the day
life had the reputation of being the
premier weekly illustrated magazine
which prided itself in its ability to
snag and illustrate important stories
slowly contacted zapruder and was able
through good timing life's deep money
pockets and the magazine's fine
reputation as perceived by zapruder to
acquire all reproduction rights in the
original film
life published a selection of the film
frames in its november 29
1963 issue
its emotional impact on the american
public was immense though additional
frames were reproduced in subsequent
issues of life over the next few years
time life's dogged refusal to allow this
key historical film to be reviewed by
the public in any form saved by what
life believed to be appropriate was the
cause for many legitimate observers to
condemn their policy
this possessive and secretive attitude
would help foster the belief among many
observers that life was significant
responsible for preventing serious
non-governmental investigation from
learning the entire truth about the
assassination
the warren commission relied heavily on
in-house studies of what the zipruder
film revealed the hearings volume
made available in november 1964
included reproductions of over 160
frames from the film
as a result for the first time
interested researchers had a chance to
examine
much of the film for themselves this was
followed in 1969 by bootleg copies of
the movie which came into general
circulation of his as the result of the
garrison investigation and the first
television broadcast of the film in
march 1975.
the film became more and more available
and criticism of time life's repressive
policy
made the company so uncomfortable that
in april 1975 the film's ownership was
transferred back to the family for one
dollar
numerous theories and books have been
produced as a result of the study of the
zapruder film
various government agencies major
corporations and institutions of higher
learning have been caught up in the
interpretation of this film's meaning
while scores of objective and subjective
amateur sleuths have attempted to exact
permit elusive truths
and what of the actual significance of
this film to the understanding of the
events of the assassination
how does it compare with other surviving
documentary materials
comparing it to the 14 other known
amateur and professional 8 and 16
millimeter films made in delhi plaza
during the assassination in the
immediate aftermath
it is my considered opinion that the
zapruder zapruder camera optics the film
stock used the film technique of the
operator and clarity of the subject make
it far superior to any other films made
it is also the only film to show the
assassination in its entirety
and from a location which graphically
displays the horror of the event and
full movements of the victims and others
in the presidential limousine thus this
is the most important artifact existing
which actually displays and visual
record the entire assassination and one
of the best if not the best in terms of
clarity
so too i would venture to say that given
the drama and content of the film this
is undoubtedly the most important film
ever made of an historic event
there are certainly other dramatic films
which have been made but none compared
to the historic nature of this event i
have been unable to think of another
comparable example of such a monumental
historic event captured on film so
completely
now given the importance of the film
when compared to other photos and films
made that day how then does this
document compare with other singular
documentary materials relating to the
assassination as explained earlier this
record is indeed unique and a
cornerstone to any examination and
investigation into the incident
a simple examination of how this film
has been so heavily used in the
government investigation and that of so
many other investigators easily bears
this out put simply this film is in my
opinion the most important surviving
document of the president kennedy
assassination
and what of the significance of the
original film versus a good first
generation copy of it
the original zapruder film is a true
artifact
in that it was the actual record made
during the assassination the one in the
same film exposed at the time of the
shooting
a physical a physical examination of it
without the necessity of electronics or
other interpretive devices save light
and enlargement takes us to the time of
the event itself and is clearer than any
multi-generation copy can be
though not a technician i can tell you
that an examination of both the original
and any copy made from the original
barring any external manipulation will
clearly show the original superior and
clarity to any copy
and should the original be within the
collection of the national archives as
the representative historical repository
of the nation
i believe beyond a doubt that it belongs
within the collection owned by the
united states it is my opinion that
given the importance of this artifact
both in its historical and potential
evidentiary nature such an artifact
should not remain in private or
corporate hands and should be in the
representative hands of the american
people
i am however somewhat uncomfortable with
the idea of direct taking of private
property by the government even when
compensated value given
perhaps i am too much of an optimist but
i would hope that such an artifact as
this which has generated quite a bit of
revenue over the years
might be considered by its current
owners
to be at a point in its history to be
appropriately given over to the american
people
it would be preserved and should be
available under correct conservation
standards
for appropriate potential future study
technologies will undoubtedly continue
to have to evolve allowing for
potentially new study of the far
superior original film
availability of the original film may
also laid arrest the present opinion of
some buffs that the film was manipulated
to get rid of proofs of conspiracy
possible commercial licensing of the
images might possibly be kept by the
owners but the original film artifact
itself
is too important to be eventually made
into a trophy by others for private or
personal gain or notoriety
this film was created by a combination
of amateur talent and serendipity its
place in american history is well
established and hopefully the present
owners will acknowledge the importance
of this film to the american people as a
whole by appropriate and generous action
thank you
questions i do
you know
i i
i differ i defer to my colleague
uh i have a very simple question i i
regret i do not know your book
uh have you personally examined the
original i've never seen the original
i've seen the archive copies and a
number of other copies how then do you
know that there is greater clarity
only because that's that's a fact of
nature when you are talking about an
original photograph as originally taken
and compare it with any copy
superiorly made as possible the copy
always
through photographic artifact through uh
other manipulations just is not as crisp
and clear as an original thank you i'm
sorry let me uh let me if i may uh just
uh erase a couple questions you use some
powerful words in your presentation
truth
uh reality
and
i raised this because
[Music]
i want to want to put this proposition
before you
that the zabruder film does not show the
assassination of the president
this depreda film shows the president
being shot
uh it does not uh
demonstrate who shot the president
uh and indeed if you compared the
zupruder film with uh the uh video
that we have of jack ruby shooting uh
lee oswald on an evidentiary basis
that's a far more powerful piece of film
if you will
than is uh than is this a pruder film
now again i'm playing a little bit
overall the devil's advocate here and so
you'll have to excuse me but but doesn't
that in essence really mean that that
other than the great and tragic
circumstance of the president being
murdered in the presence of his wife
doesn't that really mean that the
zapruder film on balance
puts more ambiguity in
to our understanding of the
assassination than it brings clarity
uh a simple question a simple answer to
that is yes and i i think i was trying
to point out that the dichotomy of the
zapruder film is the fact that if the
warren commission did not have the
zapruder film uh much of the controversy
that arose as to number of shots uh
timing and so forth uh just wouldn't
have been there because the other films
don't show in the clarity that this
film does this kind of information i
think this is an important point
for for dr hall
we we would like to operate on the on
the theory that as a piece of evidence
it should be retained because it is
conclusory but i would submit that the
value of the zepruder film lies in its
ambiguity
and it is the ambiguity and hence the
inability to come to closure with some
of the central issues related to the
assassination at least given the present
technology that makes it important as a
public record there will always be
ambiguity with his accrued film however
in my experience of of being interested
in reading about the assassination over
a 30-year period uh it's been amazing
how much information has been able to be
generated by study of the film i can't
tell in the future
what new techniques would be uh devised
which will give us
a closer aspect of the truth but no
you're not going to find in the zapruder
film a rosetta stone of of who did it
so therefore is how much is it worth to
the american public
well as as i've kind of said if if it
were on the open market i believe that
it would be
probably um
but it's a trophy it's now a trophy it's
not a piece of evidence
um
yes and no it is evidence
you certainly can find information about
it it's also a matter of the historic
record it's as important to keep
something like this as it is anything
else in history it is i believe the most
dramatic uh film that uh that was ever
uh uh
photographed uh showing a presidential
assassination
thank you
but but to continue that uh a little bit
lmh uh clearly has not yet decided and
they've had it a long time to give it to
the american people
so if you were weighing the value
should we weigh the value in a way that
would
cost what what is the top
i believe it i believe on the open
market something like that would would
be in the tens of millions of dollars i
do not believe the united states
government should pay that kind of money
for that type of film
and i'm hoping you know i'm just i'm
just a little old
activist from a small town in
massachusetts but i know that
people give
in my experience several years ago i had
a person who
made a lot less money than i uh have
make
who came in with a copy of the
declaration of independence that was
printed in
in salem in 1776
and it had on the back of it to be read
before the
clergy in danvers and i knew and we had
it
examined and it was worth
in excess of thirty thousand dollars and
this man did not hesitate and he could
have used the money to give it to
our little archives and i would think
that uh if the
zapruder family um
considering the the history of of this
film uh what am what a marvelous
demonstration
this would be to donate something like
this why don't they have a right to make
something off the off uh their good
fortune well i think they have
i think i think it's quite evident that
this
that money has been made off of it from
day one
thank you very much mr trask appreciate
your joining us again
and uh next our our final witness today
is mr art simon
he is an assistant professor in the
department of english at montclair state
university in new jersey
and he's the author of the book
dangerous knowledge the jfk
assassination in art and film published
in 1995.
professor simon
thank you for the opportunity to
address the board today i want to begin
by underscoring a theoretical point one
which mr hall has already just discussed
and that is the footage shot by
abraham's recruiter is not a window onto
the past
it is not a reproduction it is a
representation
while it is commonplace to say that film
offers us a slice of reality
a window onto the world in fact what the
pruder did was produce
a perspective
a perspective on the assassination one
that has become the dominant visual
point of view of the event
as a product and not a window
sopruder's choices and his reactions
his decision to film in color
to stand in a certain position to use
eight millimeter to move the camera as
he did
these give us a mediated form of vision
these do not give us the truth about
what took place 33 years ago
i believe there is really limited
evidentiary value left in the zakruder
film
indeed although i've not looked at the
original in its present form
it may be that if first generation
copies exist in good condition they may
be more useful to those who wish to
continue the investigation or as mr
weitzman has suggested some kind of
combination of the original and first
generation copies
now i understand that one of the
arguments for preserving the original
print holds on to the possibility that
some future optical technology might be
employed that allows the original to
yield new important information
as much as i would like to believe this
and with all due respect again to to
what mr weitzman said i think this may
well be an enabling fiction a fantasy
a fantasy that motivates further study
and fuels of faith
that someday historical ambiguities will
ultimately be made clear
the film has become a fetishized object
invested with the potential to cover up
our lack of reliable answers to many
questions
in fact
this faith in future enhancements of the
film has been a recurring trope over the
last 30 years
and of course a variety of such
processes have been applied to the film
the supreme footage has repeatedly been
cast in the role of ultimate witness and
investigators on both sides of the
debate have invested
have insisted that with the proper
scrutiny its images can render a legible
view of the event
now while three decades of analysis has
produced a significant challenge to
initial readings of the film offered by
both the government and the mainstream
press
it has also produced a multiplicity of
interpretations
a crisis of knowledge
a critique a serious critique of film's
capacity to offer unified vision and
discernible truth
in other words the application of new
technologies has not
and probably would not guarantee a
unanimity of interpretation
what then is the status of the original
film
i would suggest to you that it is a
secular relic
a material piece of the past
and for reasons that are either
psychological
or for some perhaps spiritual
individuals and the nation hold on to
such relics
i might add parenthetically that we live
in a culture which privileges origins
which
endows with significance
first things first editions books
first words spoken by baby
the we have a ceremony for the first
pitch of a ball game
we have manufactured that significance
through social convention
and ritual
in a sense the government does much the
same
why does the government preserve the
original constitution we have plenty of
copies
we know the contents
of the constitution
now while the constitution was a public
document from the beginning the supreme
film was not but still
the nation expands resources to preserve
significant objects from the past
which have had private origins
people's homes
perhaps lindbergh's plane sure the the
list is very long
perhaps these objects are maintained for
aesthetic reasons
because the textures and faded colors
bear traces of time and change
moreover
perhaps preserving such objects
functions symbolically
as the government's way of saying
historical consciousness is important
and that although the past cannot be
preserved
some index of it can be located in the
tangible artifacts which have been kept
or rediscovered
the film then is some
is part of some ongoing and perpetual
archaeology project
although on the other hand we might say
uh
that old things are just kind of cool
and we hold on to old things uh for
reasons that we really can't explain
and i'm not sure there's anything wrong
with that
and i'm not sure that there's anything
wrong with the government acknowledging
that we hold on to objects and artifacts
for that
reason i would only add to what's been
said already and that is
if federal funds are going to be spent
to keep the original film out of private
or corporate hands
as i believe it should
then some mechanism for for access needs
to needs to be maintained
uh
the criticism that's been directed at
the government for the last 30 some
years
over its handling of the investigation
of the assassination must be taken
seriously
and so i would just propose that the
board consider
whether or not uh the government
is the is the right institution to hold
on to the film and consider at least the
options
of entrusting the film to a
museum
research institution or university
thank you very much mr simon professor
simon are there questions
actually mr simon i don't know that uh
it's our i mean it belongs to the
zapruder uh family and so
obviously it belongs in the national
archives if it is sitting in the
archives
rather than a a
museum or a private institution i don't
think we could do that under our statute
but
um but of course your point that it
should be kept as an interesting one
but your if i understand what you're
saying
it's okay to keep secular relics
yes that it might be useful to keep it
for that reason for reasons that we
might uh
not explain in in courts of law so much
as uh
uh raised questions about about uh
psychology of of the nation if there is
such a thing exists
you also in your book talk a good bit
about its cultural meaning
um to the society is this also
something you're intimating when you say
that
um it is um
it should be in the public sector
because of the
failure to put it there for so many
years
i don't know from the standpoint of
culture for uh artists who want to
borrow the images and re-contextualize
them to comment on the event
on
on the last 33 years i don't know that
it's necessary for the government to
have the original
artists can use those images and
that have used them exploited them in
various ways so the original film that
ran through zapruder's camera
i don't know that it's necessary for uh
for uh it to have cultural use in in the
future
you have quite a turn of phrase i
noted enabling fiction and fetishized
objects and secular relic among them
um all of which speak to a certain kind
of
in my view marginalization of the film
in the sense of the film as a record
and i'm wondering
that
i certainly agree with you that it's
important for government to
assist us the population in terms of our
historical consciousness
and i'm wondering if you see in addition
to that if we don't in fact have a
record here and whether
what you if you have any comment to make
about the film in its record-ness my
first comment would be i'm not sure
fetishes are marginal
uh
but second there's no question that it's
important record of the event and i
think those issues have already been
addressed i don't mean to claim that the
film has no evidentiary value it has
tremendous evidentiary value i'm not
sure that it has much value left
in the sense that
i think that the
uh conflict over interpretation will
continue
we've learned important things about
what took place on that day thanks to
zapruder's film so i don't mean to
marginalize it as a as a piece of
evidence or a historical record of the
event at all
but only to suggest that even though we
have the film text that doesn't
guarantee in any way that we will all
agree about what we see
in in the uh in the text and so as mr
hall mentioned earlier ambiguities will
will persist
such as the nature of writing history
and dealing with with evidence from the
past
again on that i think
the rodney king
videotape
and uh there uh three different juries
were able to reach uh somewhat competing
uh
understandings of what that film
actually uh actually told them
the uh
the question i guess of some moment in
my mind is the extent to which we have
an obligation that is this generation
has an obligation
to make sure that generations that come
are put in at least as good a position
as we are with regard to coming to terms
with whatever evidence is there
and one of the problems that i have in
this regard is that admitting that there
are theories that explain the
assassination in terms of the federal
government itself participating and
therefore the last person you'd want to
give the of the emulsion fluid to is in
fact the wolf
recognizing that particular line of
argument it does seem to me
that uh the playing field for those who
will subsequently come
ought to be
in such order that they those who come
to play with this will be in at least as
good a position as we are today
which which would seem to indicate to me
that there ought to be some response
that would make sure that as a physical
artifact and i know you're using the
word relic in a different way but but
the preservation of that is not just a
matter of symbol but it is also
therefore matter of substance yeah i
would agree
i would agree
uh i would i would just reiterate that
i'm not sure that those future
generations will be free of the same
kind of interpretive struggle well yes
when we certainly know uh if we know
anything at all about uh the the writing
of history is that it's hard to find a
punctuation mark
and that
that what we may in fact owe future
generations is their opportunity to
interpret what
they will out of the material if they do
not have the material it is hard to
interpret it
yeah go ahead
professor i i assume you think that uh
rituals and the keeping of artifacts
while i may be fetishistic
um
some are more fetishistic more all
fetishes are equal but some are more
equal than others
and i think that's what we're talking
about and i think that's the
that seems to be an element in the
response you just gave to dr hall
you could see we've been reading too
many documents
we've been reading you too
any further questions
thank you very much the question sorry
the question you need to decide then is
how much the government pays for fetish
uh
and what that what that might be worth
thank you thank you very much professor
simon
appreciate your testimony and let me
just on behalf of the board thank uh all
of our witnesses here today who provided
testimony and opinion and thoughts and
and good advice to us
the review board will be keeping the
public record open
on this hearing for several weeks until
april 18th
so if anyone wishes to address the
subject further we'd be very happy to
receive
a public comment
it can be sent to the review board's
office at 600
e street northwest washington dc the zip
is 205 30. it's the assassination
records review board
i will also note for the record that the
board has received
thoughtful comments from
david lifton who is an author who is
concerned about this issue as well and
we've also received a letter which will
be part of the public record from
an attorney for the zapruder family
let me again thank the witnesses today
for their testimony i thought it was
very helpful and useful for the board as
it
really debates and considers what the
position of the united states should be
relative to the
camera original version of this historic
zapruder film the board is going to take
a 10 minute recess right now and then
return for
some brief additional testimony and
a relatively brief public meeting as
well
we'll be in recess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
put it all up there
okay
[Music]
mr zapruder's film is the most complete
record of the assassination of president
kennedy
shortly after the shooting mr zapruder
sold it to life magazine
it's been in the national archives since
1978.
[Music]
today and tomorrow washington journal
comes to you live from miami the